but now Toki the bar you took your
mother's a date but she wasn't that
interested in all the amazing parties
and stuff I know we went to the Vanity
Fair has a big party every year and we
went and I'm just like all my mom she's
gonna get to meet more of the actors and
um everyone here is she's like yeah I
don't know why you guys like this I'm
going home so the driver took her home
and then we went to beyoncé and jay-z's
party super fancy party now did you see
is that okay their party is like amazing
it was amazing it's it it's basically in
a car park but it's obviously been read
it's not a car park but it is and they
cover they make it look wonderful and
they say this is the last picture you'll
take as you go don't that ways when you
get down the stairs they have a sign
that says that way you're like oh okay
no phones no social media no nothing and
then you get in and you're like oh
that's why why that's why this is like
hallowed ground yeah seriously I did see
Jason there that's why I met Jason there
oh just boy yes that Jason okay the
other one with the great hair yeah
Jason was there but presumably you got
to meet jay-z and Beyonce yes so I did
not expect to see them in you know in
the flesh he wasn't expecting that at
all I was just like oh my god I'm
invited us in and then yes I was there
and and Queen Bey came up to me and
obviously looked at me like oh this is
he I'd like to talk to you and I just
did not respond in the way that I was
thinking she thought that I might
respond as in she that she obviously
came up when he was like this will be
cool and I was like oh my god crying
she's so much but also I'm guessing
probably everyone she meets bursts in it
was the correct response crying we've
all cried in car parks we have a void
that is so true we've all cried
[Music]
you